much of the coverage in the mainstream
media about bitcoin it's all about the
asset it's got a price tied to it it
goes up and down a lot and quite fast
but bitcoin also is a network it's a
payment rail that is more efficient and
allows for anyone in the world to
participate jack muller is the founder
and ceo of strike which is building on
the lightning network recently was at
the bloomberg crypto conference and he
was asked about the idea of bitcoin not
the asset but the network those payment
rails here's how jack described why this
is so valuable and why inherently every
single payment company in the world is
eventually going to adopt it the thesis
is that
the network is going to be better than
what we have today today we have these
kind of like old bifurcated like if i
walk into starbucks with western union
they're gonna be like what am i supposed
to do with that and if i try and remit
money over visa to el salvador don't
really work i think that this one open
global singular network will
all these other services will
consolidate on it so it's implied that
cash app comes on what's the use of a
network if i'm the only guy on there so
it's implied that yeah one day before i
die my wire transfer from chase to
barclays should be over a more efficient
payment rail and so i think what we all
want is open free market competition
where anyone can it's an open standard
to transfer value and it's very simple
like people think like well you know
visa is easier they don't have to touch
bitcoin visa is not easier it's slinging
around a bunch of credit liabilities all
over the place so it's not easy it's you
go online read the instructions you
implement it and you can build the
experience you want and that's where you
get
inherent free mark free market
competition which inherently suppress
suppresses pricing and you get to really
get to the bottom of things like
financial inclusion problems like if
jpmorgan chase can't bank someone
because the only uh way they make
revenue on you is if you're credit
worthy but now if the value transfer
standards open people could build
services for whoever they want if
there's a real market opportunity the
market's gonna find that right so it's
just a better world and the more people
that come on the better and for a
business like mine we benefit from the
network effects of that like jeff people
are like what happens when amazon turns
it off like i don't know probably worth
10 times more overnight now one of the
great things about this explanation is
that it highlights open networks beat
closed networks companies like visa and
mastercard they're great businesses
plenty of people use them but inherently
they box people out they're not super
efficient and they don't allow for
building on top of them and so when you
have something like bitcoin which is an
open decentralized protocol it's open
source software anyone in the world can
come in they can build on top of it they
can adopt it they can integrate it into
their own products open networks be
closed networks and the bitcoin network
is showing that you're able to do this
without a ceo without a marketing
department no board of directors and no
venture capital funding ultimately the
open network is going to be adopted you
will be able to send payments from any
one application to any other application
they don't even need to have a business
development deal they don't need to know
each other you simply have one common
open network which everyone plugs into
around the world that may sound like a
crazy crazy idea in today's world given
the side load centralized services that
we have in the traditional financial
system but that is not the world we are
going to live in 10 20 years from now
yes it is early yes there is tons of
work to do but you can already see the
signs of adoption and the signs of the
infrastructure being built
over time as more and more people figure
out the value here as more people
dedicate their time energy and money to
building these services to building this
infrastructure my guess is that adoption
is going to go through the roof the
lightning network's exploding and it's
just a matter of time until you your
company your business your product and
your competitors and colleagues all get
on board as well